ah yes I guess Kanye's buying parlor
this guy it's like
this guy just can't stay out of the
[ __ ] media
media stop it
I guess it gets clicks this this whole
[ __ ]
playing parlor because Elon Musk bought
Twitter you know Kanye West bought to
buy conservative social media platform
parlor
because he was locked out of Twitter and
Instagram for anti-semitic posts who
wants to be
this is the thing to me it's like when a
when a when a when a white guy says the
N word or like when anybody is
anti-symatic anti-Semitic
like freedom is speech I understand but
why do you want to say the n-word so bad
like it's so easy just just to not do it
yeah but freedom of speech okay fine but
why though that why who cares that much
if you care so much about free speech
just that you're like I should be able
to say the n-word on Twitter then you're
it's you may not be racist but but why
do you care that much
so it's like it's picking out a little
bit
I get words are just words but also why
like you can absolutely just say the N
word in reference or hey somebody said
this and say it and not be racist but
why do you want to say it so bad is my
point
if I say hey he said the N word and
don't say the n-word and I say the word
that doesn't make me racist but I can
easily say the n-word
that's the whole thing I don't get about
it it's like he's going on an
anti-semitic now granted I didn't read
everything you said I I saw a few things
it seemed like he was saying stuff
against Jews so the fact that he's like
[ __ ] that I'm gonna go to parlor so I
can say this stuff why though
maybe look inward maybe look inward
right
we all should look inward
like you can be on parlor and not be a
piece of [ __ ] I don't think that like
it's got the media has this [ __ ] you
know biased against parlor because you
know it's got this whole like
you know bigot connotation which I have
no idea I've never been on it I have no
no idea but like you can be on par you
could get the part of that be on parlor
and it doesn't mean you're [ __ ] you're a
bigot right
um but if you want to do anti-semitic
[ __ ] or say the n-word it's super weird
you know like I was kind of gonna feel
when the guys are popping off with the
n-word
on parlor
I'm going to get parlor
uh how big is parlor is it big how many
people are on parlor I'ma look how many
people users
on par
here we go
uh how many people use parlor 2022
what
oh that was 2021.
um
no
last year it was 32 000 new downloads so
here earlier 20 maybe so the current
stats of parlor shows that there are
over 16 million registers users
registered users in 202 earlier in 2012
to do their social media platform were
20 million for its own continuation
since its return to the Apple Store it
is oh wow they went back I didn't know
that it has experienced
32 000 new downloads overall the first
10 days of January saw 870 000 new years
across Apple devices
okay so it has so that's so many
different numbers what does it have you
know
can you get you I guess you can't get
banned from parlor
this is the thing okay so this was anti
anti-semitic Kanye West tweeted this I'm
a bit sleepy tonight but when I wake up
I'm going Defcon 3 on Jewish people in
caps wow the funny thing is I actually
can't be anti-semitic because black
people are not are actually Jews so you
guys have toyed with me and tried to
blackball anyone who opposes your agenda
dude my favorite part about this tweet
is I'm a bit sleepy tonight
what
there's so many things like you don't
like
how about how about just don't tweet
this and go Defcon 3 on Jewish people
tomorrow you can still do that like
people are going to be reading that and
be like oh well honey it's gonna be hard
to get some sleep tonight
why you see this Kanye tweet he's gonna
go death con Defcon three on us
also I'm a bit like
saying your sleep what grown man says
he's sleepy even you just say I'm tired
I'm a bit sleepy tonight but when I wake
up
I'm going Defcon 3 on Jewish people
what's deathcon 3 um what is that is
that like a Star Wars thing
the death convention
military thing wow not going military
just a rapper a guy who makes shoes
a guy who's making a guy who makes two
big clothing
death concert hey man you can't sit on
Twitter again
[Music]
can't be added systematic dude that's
the whole thing I don't think I don't
like when people say white people can't
be racist that's like saying like black
people can't be at the systematic dude
why wait wait no sorry
people say you can't be racist against
white people is what they say which is
my whole thing is dude it's got to stop
at the point where if anyone's being
judging you because of the color of you
or something like that you're I don't
give a [ __ ] dude you're racist I don't
the history is bad I get it I get it
it's harder for black people 100 but
dude you could be racist against white
people period I know that we actually
can't be there's people like Scholars
will be like yes you can't be because of
them bro I go like this
uh and honestly that makes me go Defcon
3. I would go death come forward to that
but
I don't know how many defcons there are
but I would do the maximum death I would
go right under the maximum death count
for that if somebody said you couldn't
be racist against me
[Music]
[Music]